les cascades que vous allez voir ont été
réalisés et encadrés par des
professionnels
[Musique]
donc petit livraison à faire côté des
gros lorsqu'on fait je suis bien je suis
détendu
c'est quoi ça moi je suis végétarienne
au fait comme un chat ça va tranquille
enfin c'est que c'est très mauvais pour
l'épiderme le
la tomate la grèce les ports allez on y
va
dans la match
oh
[Musique]
partout
anarchie
[Applaudissements]
sa red bull l'a déjà conduit agents dans
les déserts hockey
merde
ça fait du bien quand ça s'arrête à quoi
bon bah écoute ça le fait merci à dresde
est sympa merci sincèrement ce n'est
sympathique et familiale
enfin ce petit jeu j'étais super il nous
manque quatre boulette mais ça se
récupère merci beaucoup à robert avec
grand plaisir
[Musique]
j'espère juste vous n'avez pas brillé
puisque c'était à varier amélie sort
également à huy
non non j'ai un peu de sauce maintenant
on s'en fout bon ça va pour l'instant
vous n'avez rien de rien et l'audience
est assez puissante si tout va bien il
ya une éclaboussure et delphine et très
digne la chine c'est vraiment la classe
ça rigolait c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment la classe